airing of grievances chris what do you
got for me this week well okay i'm gonna
start off strong here all right and i'm
gonna go
uh i'm saying stick a fork in the
atlanta falcons right i'm going there
and i'm saying also for the cincinnati
bengals yeah you can kind of stick a
fork in them as well right i mean we
know they're building with it and my
point here is like julio jones aj green
trade them put them on the trade block
that's that's that's the first thing i
want to say you know hey these teams
need to be rebuilt
atlanta it's it's over i mean it's over
they need to like start back from
scratch rip the band-aid off they're too
top-heavy we see once again a few
injuries happen and they just can't
compete because of that and for me the
time is now you know calvin ridley's the
guy anyways there
and and julio jones is getting to the
point of his career where we see he's
banged up a lot he can barely practice
he plays in the game you know he's
always fighting this type of thing to me
where i i would just restart build
rebuild my team here and get some assets
for a guy like julio jones and that's
the same for aj green they got young
receivers there in cincinnati you know
boyd and higgins are becoming the go-to
guys mixon's good in the pass game they
got enough there you know they can maybe
get some significant value in a year
like this there's some teams who are
wide receiver needy that think oh we're
a super bowl contender and you might you
know get a first round pick for aj green
or you know or something like that and
certainly for julio jones to where it
could really help your football team
going forward so i'm not sure if that's
a grievance there's just something
that's uh kind of been like on my mind
this week and i think it just it's
enough it's time to move on from those
guys
i agree with you that both guys should
be traded i agree with you that the
falcons are done
i don't agree that it's time for the
bengals to throw in the towel because i
think the bengals now i
they're not throwing in their towel i
don't want to say that they're different
than like the yeah atlanta but they have
young guys there to where i feel like
right they can grow together with burrow
already
if they can get
and and look at last year what muhammad
sunu generated for the falcons the
second round pick emmanuel sanders for
the broncos the third round pick if
there's something like that lurking out
there for the tuesday after week eight
then you do it now the covet 19
situation is going to complicate the
deadline deals this year because you
basically need a one-week runway to have
a player go from one team to another
team so there may be no trades this year
i don't know but aj greene
it feels like this the sun has set on
his time in cincinnati yeah and and the
sun is rising on joe burrow and joe
mixon and tyler boyd right and uh and
they're building it a different way so
get what you can and move on but i'm not
ready i'm not ready to rule out
the the bengals being competitive this
year falcons yes bengals no yeah
and and look one of the reasons why the
bengals can't be competitive this year
is they're stuck in a division with
the ravens the steelers and the browns
ravens are three and one steelers are
three and oh browns are three in one and
here are the bengals at one two and one
we're in the basement
if they were in the nfc east they'd be
in first place yeah like the eagles one
two and one and and and this is
something that i'm gonna keep bringing
up year in and year out until they fix
it i hate this it looks good on paper
it's all configured very nice there's
symmetry
two conferences four divisions four
teams per division it all looks good but
the idea that all you have to be is the
least crappy of four awful teams and you
get a playoff birth and you get a host
to play off game is unfair
and now that we have seven teams per
conference i think it just highlights
even more
that you shouldn't have a home game
automatically because you're the none of
the above candidate
in your division that shouldn't be the
way it is and the eagles bengals
comparison
is the best way to prove that eagles
right now would host a playoff game
bengals would be left in the dust and
they got the same damn record and they
met in a game and they tied but it's all
because of your predetermined placement
in what conference and division you're
in that determines whether or not chris
you've got a playoff spot it's wrong
they need to change it
i i mean there that's a valid argument i
mean ever there really is uh
it doesn't happen like this a whole like
very often uh but when it does it's
glaring like you're talking about right
now and yeah i don't know what they do
to like fix the situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports